hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll we
all know about circadian rhythms right
we get tired at night we go to sleep we
wake up we're refreshed hopefully maybe
there's caffeine involved but there's a
cycle that we go through roughly 24
hours our bodies and our brains which
are connected to our bodies are very
much influenced by internal clocks that
let us know what time of day it is this
is why when we travel to a different
time zone we get jet lagged because
there's a mismatch between the
activities of the day and the position
of the sun in the sky versus those
internal clocks so here's something that
maybe I knew before but had forgotten
but I learned during this podcast
essentially every cell in our body has
its own circadian clock to let the cell
know what time of day it is of course
there's also systems in our bodies
because the cells talk to each other
there's the nervous system and there's
the metabolic system and so forth but it
kind of bubbles up from the individual
cells so when you get jet lagged or even
just when you get tired at night because
you know that it's bedtime it's not just
some large scale impression that your
body has it's every cell in your body is
thinking this way which is kind of a
remarkable fact you know biology is in a
great position these days it's a very
exciting time there's enormous amounts
of data coming in of course we can
analyze genes and molecular biology
questions in much greater detail than we
ever could before and there's also tools
to analyze that with great computational
power machine learning and AI all that
kinds of stuff plus of course there are
questions to which we don't know the
answers in physics if you listen to my
long solo podcast one of the challenges
is that we have theories that fit the
data really well in the regimes where we
can experimentally access in biology
don't worry that is not the case it's
very easy to ask questions that are very
important but we don't know the the
answer but it's plausible that we can
find the answer so today we're talking
to Rosemary Brown who is a biologist
molecular biologist slash engineer at
Northwestern who works at the sort of
systems level of biology right rather
than looking at this particular organism
and its whole life cycle or for that
matter this particular organ in an
organism she looks at the various
complexes the various networks the
various systems that hook together
inside biological organisms the
Circadian rhythm is one of them but
there's many different ways that this
kind of Paradigm plays out it's very
different than in physics where you can
find a simple spherical cow you know
abstract away all the complications and
just look at the harmonic oscillator or
whatever in biology very often we have
these intricate complex networks that
are talking to each other and so that's
we're going to explore today before
going on to that let me just mention I
haven't mentioned in a while we're still
doing the mindscape big picture
scholarship so this is something where
people who are going to college going to
universities can apply for this
scholarship it's ten thousand dollars if
you win so it just goes right to your
tuition it is aimed at uh youngsters who
are going to go to college who are
interested in the big picture so who are
interested in you know not necessarily
doing something applied or primarily
financially rewarding but thinking about
the Big Ideas people who want to
concentrate in fundamental physics or
philosophy or mathematics or for that
matter history or literature or
economics or what have you as long as
it's that thinking deeply about the
fundamentals kind of aspect those are
the applicants we want so if you're
interested in applying or if you're
interested in donating to the big
picture scholarship fund go to
bold.org
scholarships slash mindscape bold.org b
o ld.org is a wonderful organization
that helps people crowdsource um these
kind of scholarships last year we gave
out two scholarships it's just very
heartwarming that you can contribute to
the education of some young student
especially ones that might not you know
come from academic backgrounds Etc so
it's a very nice thing you can do
there's also a link on our mindscape
homepage which is just
preposterousuniverse.com podcast if you
want to go directly from there so thanks
for everyone who has been donating we've
been getting donations all year we gave
out two scholarships last year let's
hope we could do even better this year
so with that let's go
foreign
[Music]
Rosemary Brown welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you so much for having me
let me ask about the big picture here
that's my favorite thing to ask about as
an outsider you know it seems to me that
there's a shift in the last few decades
or whatever in biology from Talking
largely about
organisms or species to now thinking
about systems and networks and and
genomes and so forth is that an accurate
perception as an outsider I I think it
is yeah I think in large part it's been
driven by the revolution in micro uh and
molecular biology profiling Technologies
right so we're now able to assay gene
expression in elaborate detail
um we can look at genetic variations in
extraordinary detail and we need a way
to make sense of all of that information
right and so trying to relate what we
measure in this 20 000 dimensional
feature space of gene expression to what
we can see under the microscope or in a
patient who has just walked into a
clinic
relating those two things to each other
is a major challenge that we have now
and one way to approach that problem is
to look at it from A System's point of
view and to think about what the network
of interactions between those
microscopic elements are that produce
the macroscopic features that we observe
so when I just uh out of my head came up
with systems and networks are those the
right words
uh yeah I would say so yeah okay good
and it's largely because you know more
data isn't I don't want to say it's not
always better more data is always better
but it's not useful by itself right we
need to get the right way to squeeze the
information out of the data yeah it's
not useful by itself and it's it's also
not necessarily clear to me that that
it's necessarily that what we are able
to measure easily is what the system
actually cares about sure right
um and so you know one can imagine
measuring many many things and at the
end of the day it's it's really a low
dimensional set of of interactions that
govern what is what a cell is going to
do and everything else is a consequence
of that that we're measuring
um and so trying to identify which are
the the state variables that the system
actually cares about I think is a as a
massive challenge yeah and so in my
language we measure a lot of things but
but book but what should we be paying
attention to exactly so in my language
it's all about course graining and
emergence right I mean in a physics
system my favorite example is in the
earth there's 10 to the 50th atoms and
to figure out how the Earth orbits the
sun we don't need to know what those
atoms are doing we just need to know a
small number of variables the center of
mass and the velocity but the point is
that in physics it's kind of obvious
what we need to know and and that
happens to coincide with what we can
easily measure in biology everything is
always much more complicated yeah
so your lab if you were to explain your
lab to um a stranger on the street what
exactly are you trying to figure out
ah um everything no
um so my my interest is really in how
how living systems self-organize and I
approach this problem from a purely
computational point of view
um so we collaborate extensively with
experimentalists who ask interesting
biological questions and produce data
and can then test our models
um but we do not do that directly
but that gives me a certain amount of
flexibility in the types of things that
I study so
um so if you think about living systems
they exhibit these beautiful
self-organized uh structures and
processes at every single scale right at
the molecular level proteins assemble
into macromolecular complexes that carry
out certain functions the cells are
arranged into tissues with very very
reliable patterning
those tissues interact in a
multi-cellular organism to enable it to
to live and move and do all of the
things that it does the organisms
themselves interact in ecological
networks and in societies
um and so the
what gives rise to all of those Dynamics
is really a
it's a mystery that I'm absolutely
passionate about solving and I've I've
made very little Headway I um but but I
am struck by the fact that we're now at
a point where data collection is
easy
um relatively speaking and computational
power is plentiful and so we can start
to scratch the surface of those
questions you're young you have plenty
of time to answer these questions
we have great expectations here but am I
getting the impression that you are a
more or less theoretical biologist in
the same sense that I'm a theoretical
physicist yeah I I was actually trained
as a theoretical physicist and I I
drifted into biology because I was
interested in complex systems and uh and
and living systems were the most
compelling example of complex systems
that I that I could find right so so I
slowly got got drawn over to questions
in biology but my training is is purely
theoretical how far all the way up to
the PhD
um so yeah my PhD is in theoretical
physics this is hilarious so I I have to
promise the audience I did not know that
because again and again I have guests on
mindscape and they reveal halfway
through that oh yeah I was a physics
undergraduate or whatever and yet
they're studying political science or
sociology or economics so okay I get it
it makes sense to me now why you think
that way but it's funny because as a
biology Professor you still have a lab
even though you're a theorist yeah I
mean it's a dry lab right so so all of
our experiments are in silico and and we
work really closely with with the
experimentalists who I collaborate with
um you know students who who work with
me often spend time in the the wet lab
of my collaborators
um I definitely did that as well
um when I was you know making my
transition into theoretical biology
um and and it's it's been a wonderful
journey and and it's it's been a lot of
fun to to be working at that interface
um it has its challenges of course right
we
we're trying to think in different ways
where we use different language to
describe phenomena but at the end of the
day we're we're kind of both me and my
experimentalist collaborators are
interested in the same fundamental
questions and so we're kind of able to
come together from those two
perspectives in physics of course it's a
well-established idea that we have
theorists we have experimentalists we
hire both or whatever do your biology
colleagues look at you slightly scans as
someone who does not ever get their
hands wet
right I think I think in part because of
this revolution in molecular biology
there has been a realization that that
the ways in which we think about
biological systems and try to make the
links between the microscopic and the
macroscopic
it requires different sorts of
perspectives
um and so I think you know I see an
increase in the diversity of approaches
that biology departments take and and
mine is certainly one of them so I think
that that sort of um
looking at scans or that skepticism of
of non-wet uh biology research is is
diminishing as as its power is sort of
revealed good to know and uh I was
amused on your website to see the word
omics used as a as a I don't know back
uh construction from there are things
called genomics and proteomics and
metabolomics and so forth so we just
we'd lump them together and call them
all omix uh maybe explain to the
audience what that is
yeah so um so
back to to what we're all taught as the
central dogma of molecular biology right
you have a genome it's encoded in DNA
those genes are comprised of some
sequence of of bases that that code for
uh a protein in the end but there's an
intermediate step where the the gene is
transcribed into mRNA and then the MRNA
has been translated into protein
um and about
20 or more years ago now
um there was a development of microarray
technology and
in what this technology was designed to
do was to simultaneously assay
genome-wide
the abundances of all of the mrnas in a
given sample so the idea is this you
have a gene it codes for a protein but
how much of that protein is produced
depends on how many copies of that Gene
are made in mRNA okay and so if you can
measure how many copies of mRNA you have
for that protein for that particular
Gene you can use that as a proxy for how
abundant that protein is and maybe then
as a proxy for how much of the function
that that protein carries out is
actually being carried out in your
sample
um previously the way that mRNA
abundance was acid was one gene at a
time and microarrays enabled us to do
this for ten thousand genes at a time
and so now you get this incredibly Rich
snapshot of gene expression for nearly
every Gene in the genome
right
um and so that was referred to as
genomics and transcriptomics since we're
looking at the transcript level and you
can also look at Gene sequences and so
that's really when we talk about
sometimes genomics is used as a
catch-all term but if we're being really
really specific about it the genomics
refers to the sequence of the DNA and
how much yours might vary from mine or
two different organisms from one another
or cancer cell from a healthy tumor cell
the transcriptomics is kind of the next
layer up in the regulation how much of
the MRNA is produced proteomics looks
directly at the protein abundances and
so on and so forth
um and we can do all of these things now
in high throughput right so it's not
just mRNA we can do it at the genome
level we can do it at the protein level
we have now next Generation sequencing
technology so nobody is using microarray
anymore they're all doing sequencing
which means that we can really look in
detail across the entire Genome of what
a given sample is doing uh
yeah I guess this is the point where I
ask my favorite question to ask
biologists which is what is a gene
in in DNA language right I mean it seems
to be some functional unit of the DNA
but maybe the boundaries are a little
fuzzy and people disagree the boundaries
can be a little fuzzy so so the a given
region of the genome can code for
different isoforms of the gene right so
it could be truncated in different
places it could be spliced in different
ways
um and which of those isoforms is
actually expressed by a cell can change
under different circumstances so for
example we know of particular genes
where depending on the temperature at
different isoform of that same gene is
expressed and because you have a
different isoform you have a slightly
different protein or perhaps you have
the same protein but it has different
regulatory properties so it might be
easier to to uh interact with by some
other
um
some other regulatory element
so
so the it is fuzzy in that sort of way
right
um there's you know we're we're taught
to think of of
genes and proteins and enzymes as as
these highly specific entities right
like yeah you know when you're in in
your first biology class in in high
school or in college you're kind of
taught this lock and key
model for for how proteins interact with
one another and it
a lot of
specificity and promiscuity in in The
Binding of proteins to one another and
what regulatory elements are targeted by
which regulatory proteins
and so so
nailing down what a given Gene does is
it can be challenging and I think to be
honest I it's something that that I'm
actually a little bit opposed to
um in the sense that that I think that
that making this Assumption of
of specificity and of this lock and key
mechanism I don't think it's borne out
by by the data and I think that if you
do an analysis
with that assumption you limit the types
of things that you're able to discover
it's interesting because we've long ago
gotten rid of the idea of intelligent
design we know that these biological
organisms evolve through natural
selection but also again and again we
come across a situation just like when
he said where we have an explanation or
an account of something and then we
realize it's not quite that simple or it
doesn't work in quite that way and and I
wonder how much of that is because we
sort of have an intuition that grows up
from designed systems where if there's a
part it has a purpose and there's a
clear thing that it does but because
all the stuff that we see in biological
organisms have just sort of come about
because the whole system was successful
the boundaries are not always so clear
in biology
absolutely and I think that one could
make
energetic Arguments for proteins having
multiple functions right then you only
need to make make one of them to carry
out multiple things I think that one can
also make probabilistic Arguments for
why that may be the case in the sense
that
um that that having a multi-functional
protein allows you to do a little bit of
bat hedging
um and you know I I I'm saying this kind
of as a conjecture when it comes to
proteins you know we had this this pair
of papers
um with my former student Gary Wilk
where we looked at the role of micrornas
which are small non-coding RNA molecules
and
um and there we know that
um that their role in binding and
regulating genes is pretty promiscuous
so
um if you'd like I can elaborate on that
please so so micrornas are short
non-coding RNA molecules
um six to eight bases long
right so very very short and
they bind to
mRNA molecules which code for a specific
genes and proteins
and they either inhibit the production
of the protein by being bound to the
MRNA molecule or they trigger the
degradation of the MRNA in either case
the end result of the microrna binding
to the MRNA is that it down regulates
the production of the the targeted
protein
but I told you that that micro RNA is
very very small only six to eight bases
and so it could bind many many many
genes right that that's a very short
sequence which it might bind to
um and so micro a given micro RNA may
have many mRNA targets and a given mRNA
because it's hundreds possibly thousands
of bases long might be targeted by
multiple micrornas
so there's a many-to-many relationship
between the micrornas and their targets
and and so this kind of flies in the
face of that assumption that we're kind
of taught early on which is you know
this sort of one-to-one it does one
thing
um very very mechanistically
um and so we wanted to to
ask the question well why why would you
produce a regulatory molecule a micro
RNA that is completely non-specific in
its binding right where it might have
possibly hundreds of targets
and
we thought well one reason you might
want to do such a thing or evolve such a
mechanism is as a way to exert systems
level control over an entire process by
redundantly targeting different elements
of that system right so that if the
micro RNA doesn't bind to one particular
mRNA maybe it binds to the MRNA of
different Gene and it doesn't matter
which one it's hit the whole system as a
whole is is down regulated
and so what Gary and I did was to look
for statistical evidence of this type of
systems level control
um in tcga which is the cancer genome
Atlas and it's a repository of one of
those
giant genomics projects thousands upon
thousands of samples and each of them
has DNA data mRNA data micro RNA data
proteomic data Etc so it's a wonderful
wealth of data and so what we want to
know was do we see evidence of the
systems level control if we look in in
this data
um the way that we did that was to say
okay if if a micro RNA targets a
particular Gene then we expect that when
the micro RNA abundance goes up the
abundance of the target RNA will go down
we know that if you look at particular
microrna Gene pairs that's not really
born out so you don't always see that at
the single Gene level but what if we
were to take all of the genes that we
know to play a role in a particular
biological function in a particular
pathway and we summarize in some
statistical way the expression level of
all of the genes in that pathway and use
that as a coarse-grained measure
of how active that pathway is
can we then identify particular micro
RNA pathway pairs whereas the microrna
RNA goes up the pathway activity
summarized through non-linear Dimension
reduction of the gene expression goes
down and in fact we were able to
identify exactly that
and is this an example of the circuits
that you talk about uh you we use this
language of
circuitry right of nodes and networks
and and things connecting them so like
rather than saying you know putting your
finger on a certain mnra
mRNA and saying here's what it does you
say you know here's all the flow of
different things you talked about
channels I guess
um and you know here's how it all adds
up to some collective Behavior yeah so
in that particular paper we just treated
the the pathway not as a network but
just as a collection of genes
um but now in in kind of work that's
grown out of that as well as some other
studies now we're starting to take into
account what we think is the the wiring
diagram and I'm I'm making air quotes
although your your listeners cannot
cannot see them
um but but the wiring diagram of of
these Pathways so that's a network of
putative interactions uh between the
genes or the gene products really uh
that carry out some particular
biological function and the reason that
I put air quotes around it is that
what we know of those wiring diagrams is
incomplete right we don't know all of
the interactions just because we haven't
discovered them all yet we obtain those
wiring diagrams those pathway networks
from databases which inevitably will
have some errors yeah
right
um and and again there's this issue of
probably any given element has more than
one role maybe we haven't discovered all
of them yet so it it may be that those
those networks are sparser than
then they in the database than they are
in in reality right but
a starting point for trying to
understand what is connected to what and
what the flow of information or the flow
of a signal through this collection of
genes might be and is there some hope
that or maybe it's already true I don't
know
um that we achieve a complete list of
all the circuits of all the networks
that are relevant or or they're
completely different kinds of circuits
we're talking about and one person's
circuit is another person's you know
noise I'm not sure
that's a really great question
um
[Laughter]
whenever somebody asks is there hope
to say yes of course of course there is
um but but I think it's a I I think it's
I I think it's actually quite a
challenging problem right so so there's
this big problem of how do you
how do you discover those those wiring
diagrams with those networks and now
because we have so much omix data yeah
one could say okay well what we'll do is
we'll go to that omics data and we will
look for patterns of correlation in that
data and from those correlation patterns
we will infer some sort of network
structure
and uh We've made a little tiny bit of
progress on that but but it's it but not
very much and and not very much because
at the end of the day it's at this point
a pretty grossly underdetermined problem
okay right in that the number of
interactions that one could have amongst
the things that we are measuring
is much larger than the number of
observations that we've collected gotcha
so where as far as hope is concerned
sure but we're not at the level now
where everyone agrees on what the
circuits are in the same way they agree
on what organs we have in our body yeah
good and it reminds me a little bit I
hadn't thought of this until just now of
we had Judea Pearl on the podcast
talking about causal networks right
um he's more thinking of social science
or medicine you know what kind of
interventions can have a good outcome uh
when you draw your little diagrams uh do
you imagine asking questions about what
causes what what what uh node in the
diagram has a causal influence on the
behavior of what other nodes
um
so yeah I think that's at the end of the
day that's that's what we'd like to
understand from these systems from my
perspective it
I'm interested Less in what causal
effect does OneNote have on what other
node and more about what causal effect
does OneNote have on the behavior of the
system as a whole so if a particular
node were subject to mutation what would
that mean for for the Dynamics of of the
entire network right how robust is the
network to damage in particular
particular regions if I recover
some coarse green statistical property
of that network is that enough to
recover its functional Behavior or do I
need to recover every node and every
Edge in detail right and maybe this is a
slightly Askew question but is there a
sharp bright line between biological
networks of this form and other possible
chemical reaction networks uh are there
things that we see in the biological
context that we just don't see elsewhere
chemical or bio physical interactions
between molecules and so in that sense
I I think there you can think of them as
as a chemical interaction Network as
well okay but do we do we in nature but
not in
biology and you know and things that
happen outside nature do we see reaction
networks of this richness and depth or
is biology special if only because it's
more complex than other things
um
I
I mean biology is especially in terms of
its its complexity in terms of its
complicatedness in terms also in the
fact that it is far from equilibrium of
course yes right so
um and and it's adaptive right so so
it's those networks are not necessarily
constant in time
good I mean it's it's biology is
simultaneously not in equilibrium but
almost in a steady state for some
purposes right I mean in in statmek we
talk about non-equilibrium steady state
sometimes right yeah and and
yeah I would I would say that the the
analogy Works in biology
um and I think that's one of the great
Mysteries right we have incredibly
reliable phenotypes if you think about
organismal development it's
astonishingly reliable despite
environmental variation despite genetic
variation like occasionally things can
go wrong but by and large despite all of
these sources of of variation and
fluctuations it's extremely relaxed
that says to me that says that there is
that that there's a wide Basin of
Attraction yeah right
um and so so I think that's part of why
I'm very motivated to take these systems
and network views in that it
to have a wide Basin of Attraction it
means that the system is not fine-tuned
right fine-tuned would suggest that
there's a a very very
narrow range of the state space that
leads to a particular outcome
um and if it's not fine-tuned I I
then I think it has to all be systems
level effects well it goes hand in hand
with what we said before uh mechanical
things tend to be brittle right you
break a single wire and then your
computer doesn't work but biology has to
be a little resilient
good yeah okay so that's that was thank
you for indulging me those more uh
semi-philosophical questions let's get
back down to uh the nitty-gritty of what
you do because uh like we said before
these networks are complicated a lot of
data in here a lot of things going on
computers are going to certainly play a
role in your analysis but also machine
learning or what these days we're
supposed to call AI I'm sure uh plays an
important role
yeah
um so so we do quite a lot of that
um and and you know
I think
we've seen a huge revolution in machine
learning and statistical learning
techniques are incredibly powerful the
computers are now incredibly powerful
and so you can do things now that were
impossible five ten years ago
um the data sets are very large albeit
still not large enough for
um for deep learning to be as effective
as as I think we would like to be
but I think also that there's a little
bit of a danger in just taking the
wealth of data that we've collected and
um generic in some sense machine
learning algorithms and pushing the data
through and crossing your fingers and
hoping that that something of value is
discovered
in
in a naive way
we already know a lot about biological
systems so for example let's think about
the the this problem of inferring
interaction networks right or Pathways
we already have some information about
which genes code for proteins that act
as transcription factors and would
therefore regulate
by binding to the DNA the expression of
other genes so we know something about
the biochemistry of these elements
simply taking the correlation structure
and the data pushing it into a machine
learning model and saying okay can you
give me a minimal Network without taking
into account
that biochemical information seems to me
to be a little bit
naive right like we're not we're not
using what we already have and so one of
the things that my group is is very
interested in is are there ways to
integrate the information that we
already have
even though it might be incomplete or
somewhat erroneous
into the machine learning methods that
we are using to make new discoveries
so that's very interesting but let me
bring up the fact that is also very
interesting that when we build chess or
go playing machine Learning Systems uh
one of the great discoveries was don't
ruin it by giving it anything that a
human being thinks is a good chess
playing strategy it's much better to
just let the computer play games against
itself a gajillion times and figure
things out for itself than to give it
any hints so you're saying that maybe in
biology it's different or that's a
hypothesis that we might shoot down I I
mean I think I I well first of all I see
no reason not to do both right there's
absolutely no reason to take not to take
both approaches I do think that
um that trying to understand what a cell
or what a tissue is doing is perhaps a
bit more complicated than
um than learning how to play go or how
to play chess simply because the number
of of components in this particular game
is much larger bigger yeah right and so
so if you're if the goal is to to search
a a space of possible states to find the
ones that correspond to a winning
strategy in go or chess or life
um it might help to constrain your
search space a little bit if the number
of players is very large sure so are
there intelligent ways to constrain that
space
you did bring up the number twenty
thousand what did that refer to what are
the twenty thousand of so that's
the approximate number of uh of genes
that we obtain when we do gene
expression profiling
um in a human subject it's different for
different organisms so some have more
some have less but in general when
you're doing transcriptomics for any
given sample and now we can do it at the
Single Cell level so for any given cell
you're looking at twenty thousand
measurements
is that 20 000 genes
yeah that's 20 000 my distinct micro
rnas uh mrnas excuse me but is that Mr
Nice forgive me my complete ignorance
here is that saying that the human
genome contains 20 000 genes or is this
a statement about our ability to measure
both okay
and good then now we can put it all
together right so we have 20 000 genes
or or mrnas and we collect a lot of data
you have an overming amount of data and
as we said at the very start we're
interested in this sort of emerging
Collective Behavior right they're sort
of it's not just twenty thousand it's
twenty thousand in some combinatorial uh
array right like you know different
genes play with each other in different
ways a huge number of possible things
going on but a relatively small number
of things actually do go on and and
that's what the machine learning for
example is trying to help us with yeah
exactly so so so I would say you know
from uh from a mathematical perspective
the way I would put it is that we have
observations in this 20 000 dimensional
feature space and we think that those
observations lie on a very low
dimensional manifold within that twenty
thousand dimensional space right that
not all
locations in that 20 000 dimensional
space correspond to A system that that
can live right and so the idea is can we
discover the geometry of that manifold
can we then use it to say what it means
to have variation along a particular
direction of that manifold what does it
mean to deviate from that manifold
um and and can we use
the location of an observation on that
manifold to say something about its Its
Behavior as a whole good and
I mean you just asked a bunch of
rhetorical questions uh how much
progress has been made is this like
brand new frontier or do we have our
handles on a bunch of answers to some of
the questions you just asked
right so yeah so
linear dimension reduction then
learning has been
you know a a hot topic for for a while
now okay um and so we have you know
there there have been many algorithms
proposed some of which can be
demonstrated to be equivalent to one
another mathematically
um in general the the idea behind them
is to use the local geometry of your
observations to try to decide what what
is the surface on which those
observations lie and then you go to the
next local neighborhood and you kind of
stitch them together like this patch
um so that's the hand wavy description
of them
um there are still some challenges right
so one question that one can ask is well
if you're using the the local geometry
to decide the what the where the
manifold is in in some region of this 20
000 dimensional space
um how big of a local neighborhood
should you take right and that question
of scale
um is one that is still in some sense
unanswered so how do you tune that scale
should you be looking at the same scale
in every region of the data right
um probably not how do you tune it
adaptively so yeah okay good yeah okay I
so we see it coming we're going to be
able to figure out what are the sort of
relevant variables the immersion course
grained way of talking about all these
things what good will it do us how does
this help us understand biology or you
know cure disease or whatever it is you
want to do
I think the the the ultimate goal is if
you have some understanding of the
relationship between
between proteins and genes and Gene
products you might be able to make a
guess as to what you could Target
therapeutically
um you might be able to develop better
Diagnostics so I think that's that's the
ultimate goal is to have an
understanding that would lead to the
generation of new hypotheses that would
ultimately lead to to Better Health
outcomes
um you know one one area in which we've
been somewhat successful it's a pretty
lofty goal right but one area in which
we've made a little bit of Headway on
that front has been in the work that
I've done on circadian rhythms and it
you know there's abundant
epidemiological evidence that suggests
that the time of day that your body
thinks it is is absolutely crucial for
how you metabolize food having
metabolized drugs whether it's aligned
with your environment turns out to be
crucial in in your risk for various
diseases
um and we don't really understand fully
the links between all of those things
but if we're able to measure
physiological time then maybe we can use
that measurement to inform things like
when you should take a blood pressure
drug or when you should take
um
when chemotherapy should be delivered
and so so
using multi-gene expression profiles to
obtain a measure of physiological time
was one of the things that we worked
with on and and and there we were
somewhat successful with it so so that
might actually have some some benefit
within the near term I'm hopeful let's
actually dig into the Circadian rhythm
stuff because I will confess as we are
recording this podcast
uh yesterday I flew home from England
and I'm totally jet-lagged so this idea
that you know what time of day I eat
things is gonna I mean let me phrase it
as a question are you saying that where
I am in my circadian rhythm I.E what
time my body thinks it is
um affects how I metabolize food
yeah it affects how you metabolize food
and when you eat also affects your
circadian phase right so there so the
Circadian rhythm itself is a
self-sustained 24-hour oscillation right
um and so even in the absence of light
and dark or other time giving cues
you'll still roughly have a 24-hour day
it's it's in humans it's a little bit
longer than 24 hours but it's still an
approximate 24 hour Rhythm
um but as you are now experiencing when
those cues uh occur your your circadian
phase will shift
um that takes some time uh
as as you are now very abundantly aware
um and it can be influenced by light as
well as by feeding behaviors so when you
eat can have a powerful effect on how
quickly you recover from jet lag
eat in the morning is what I've heard
that was the next question okay clinical
and experimentalist collaborators yeah
eight in the morning even if you don't
usually in the morning
Apparently that is so so now this is not
my direct line of research but what I
have been told by by my colleagues who
study this is that yeah so so high
calorie intake in the morning tends to
be a a better phase resetting signal
than than eating at other times a day
um light in the morning isn't is well
understood to be a powerful phase
resetting signal I'll warn you ahead of
time we're going to have you know this
lovely conversation about networks and
signals and and gene expression and so
forth and what people remember is eight
in the morning to get over jet lag
that's what people oh yeah
news you can use I like that but but
let's let's connect it back to what
you're doing so we have this because
this is fascinating to me we have all
this molecular activity going on in our
bodies and as a physicist I'm interested
how the time scales connect to each
other I mean ultimately it's all
chemistry in our bodies and chemical
reactions happen relatively quickly like
where in our bodies does it know that
the day is 24 hours long and that there
should be cycles and rhythms of that
duration
so so this is really really fascinating
so uh nearly every cell in your body and
almost every living cell on Earth it's
highly evolutionarily conserved has a
molecular oscillator with an approximate
24-hour period
um
in mammals and fruit flies it's a
transcription translation feedback loop
so essentially you have genes that are
transcribed they're then translated into
proteins those proteins then regulate
the transcription of other genes that
are part of this feedback loop and it's
a negative feedback loop with time
delays because all of these steps take
time and anytime you have negative
feedback with time delays you can
sustain oscillations and so there is
this core clock circuit
in nearly every cell and this was a
somewhat surprising discovery the fact
that it existed in every cell because
yeah one could could conjecture well you
only really need it in the brain and
then the brain can control everything
else
um and so the discovery that there are
peripheral clocks was
um was was quite exciting
um and and it it raises some interesting
questions like
why would you why would you produce a
clock in every single cell
um and and I have some
hypotheses about that one of which is
that it's one way to allow processes to
be coordinated and orchestrated across a
spatially extended system like you or me
without Community direct communication
between the elements of that system
right if you've got to watch and I've
got to watch it's enough to say that
we're going to meet to record a podcast
we don't need to be in constant
communication up until that point and
when you say oscillator just because
again physics training in me I'm
thinking of like a pendulum going back
and forth but you're thinking of a
little collection of chemical
concentrations going up and down is that
true yeah that's that's correct so it's
a chemical oscillator not a mechanical
one correct yeah and every cell within
our bodies I know you just said that and
you even said that it's amazing but it's
amazing so yeah very nearly so um so
there I mean you know
there was a beautiful beautiful study
um done by by John hoganesh's lab a
number of years ago and it was it was
called the mouse circadian Atlas And
basically what they did was they took
every single tissue in the mouse and
they did Time series gene expression
measurements for each of those tissues
um and they discovered genes that were
under circadian control in every one of
those those tissues and those genes
included the core clock genes
and but let me let me home in on this
particular question where does the
number 24 Hours come from right I mean
it must be that this particular
oscillator is pretty darn tune you know
someone has to design the clock in some
way and and chemistry biology has
figured out how to get this rather long
time scale to pop out of some very quick
interactions
right
um so so yeah so this is obviously
something that has evolved on earth
right with its 24-hour day so so there's
there's reason to believe that it's that
it's favorable to have a clock that
would enable you to anticipate time of
of day right
um but but you raised something really
interesting and that's that you know it
has this
pretty robust 24-hour period what's
curious about it is that it has this
robust 20 approximate 24 hour period
across a very wide range of temperatures
and that's pretty surprising because we
would expect that chemical reactions are
going to run faster higher temperatures
and so the clock should speed up but it
doesn't it's temperature compensated
um this is obviously very useful
um for cold-blooded organism but also
for us if you consider the fact that you
know the temperature on your skin is
very different from the temperature in
the core of your body it's important to
have them be at approximately the same
period how temperature compensation is
achieved is still not well understood
okay
um and there's another wrinkle too it's
temperature compensated but it's not
temperature insensitive so fluctuations
in environmental temperature can shift
the phase of the clock so it's not just
completely isolated somehow from from
thermal information
um but the the period is compensated
you know it's very similar in mechanical
wrist watches right it's very hard to
make a watch that
keeps the same amount of time no matter
what temperature it is or other
conditions absolutely and in fact you
know that was when when Harrison was
designing his chronometers for uh for
the the British royal Navy that was
achieving temperature compensation was a
major challenge right because if the
clock on board your ship starts running
faster or slower you can go off course
[Laughter]
does this little chemical oscillator in
every one of our cells communicate with
the rest of the world for one but
actually let me let me back up cells are
pretty tiny how is their room in a Cell
for this and then how does it then
connect to the rest of what's going on
in the cell and outside
right so so
cell is a pretty densely packed
environment
um it's it's big enough to allow for for
the expression of the core clock
components
um sorry does the clock literally have a
size or is it sort of diffuse so these
are these are chemical reactions right
it's a chemical oscillator so we expect
that those things are going to be
diffusing and binding and unbinding Etc
good okay
and then how does it communicate
elsewhere
really good question I don't have an
answer I don't think we have an answer
so there are certain signaling molecules
that we know exist so
melatonin for example is produced by the
brain a couple hours before you go to
sleep
um it serves as as a signal to
to other cells right
um and so that's one form of that
communication there's obviously the
nervous system but the coupling between
the various oscillators and the various
cells I I we don't necessarily know what
achieves that there are some really
interesting work from Karen Esther's
group in Florida
um where they looked at
um a phase resetting in Mouse muscle
tissue when they changed when the mice
were allowed to exercise
right so the mice will run on a wheel
given the opportunity and so basically
they they deprived the mice of the wheel
at particular times of day to see what
that would do to the the Circadian phase
of the muscle tissue to give them jet
lag basically
but nothing else was jet lag right so
the light cues for the same feeding was
the same the only thing that they
perturbed was was when the the mice
could exercise
um and and what they discovered was that
exercise was a very powerful zeitge
Gaber a very powerful phase resetting
queue for the the muscle clock right
um and so you know this raises the
question of to what degree is it
actually the physical coupling between
cells that might mediate the the cell
cell you know coupling of of the
oscillators I do not know
um I I think those those experiments
still need to be done that's so much fun
it's so easy in biology just to like
bump up against fundamental things that
are easy to ask and we don't know the
answer to
so the oscillators uh you know are are
keeping track it sounds like a fairly
simple thing like an oscillator is
literally the simplest possible physics
system but before we were talking about
these very complicated chemical networks
so is there a connection there or is the
oscillator part of the network or is an
oscillator secretly much more
complicated than I think it is
so so
the oscillator is is part of the network
in the sense that there are many genes
that are under circadian control so
those core clock components right our
our transcription factors that then
regulate the expression of hundreds
maybe even thousands of genes Downstream
so that Mouse circadian Atlas paper that
I mentioned from from hoganesh's group
earlier
um
what they found was that nearly half of
the mouse genome was under circadian
control in some tissue
all right so it wasn't nearly half in
any given specific tissue but if you
look across the Mouse as a whole nearly
half
um and and so that suggests that the the
clock is is playing a significant role
in
um in a variety of biological processes
what we've seen in our research in
collaboration with raviolata's group
here at Northwestern
is that the the clock is is crucial to
metabolism and to lifespan and to egg
laying in fruit flies so you can do
these experiments that Ravi has done
where you take a fruit fly and you
subject it to lower temperatures or to
dietary restriction so you deprive it of
some calories without starving it and a
normal fly when subjected to these
slightly unfavorable conditions actually
does something a little bit unexpected
it lives longer so
dietary restriction usually results in
life spani elongation yes lower
temperature also results in life span
elongation in the fruit fly
um
and you know you can come up with all
sorts of of theories and just those
stories about why that might be like you
know total energy consumed over the
lifespan or something like that it turns
out that in order to observe that
lifespan elongation the fruit fly needs
an intact clock if you knock out one of
the core clock components by mutating a
gene
helpfully known as clock you get an
arithmic fruit fly
um and that fruit fly
has the same approximate lifespan
regardless of the calories that it has
available to it
and so it it seems that the there's not
only hundreds possibly thousands of
genes that are under circadian control
but which genes are under circadian
control has a big influence on these
macroscopic outcomes that we're able to
observe you know one of the very first
podcasts I did was with Colleen Murphy
uh of Princeton who studies aging and
it's interesting like yeah you knock out
some genes things like that our life
expectancy changes or not hours but you
know they're using uh nematodes
um does this kind of thing
open up prospects for dramatically
changing human lifespans if we were to
understand these networks better go
ahead it's late in the podcast you're
allowed to speculate a little bit I mean
I I would love to say yes I think that
that that's a hard question to answer
yes or no to I I will say this something
that that has long been observed is that
there are sleep and circadian
disruptions that are associated with
neurodegeneration
um and circadian patterns to symptoms in
neurodegenerative diseases like
Alzheimer's
and so one of the things that we are
looking at now is what are the patterns
of circadian gene expression that are
associated with healthy aging versus
people who have pre-clinical and
clinical Alzheimer's disease
um and so hopefully that research will
will give us some insights as to the
links between you know circadian rhythms
and and at least healthy aging I don't
know about lifespan okay fair enough I I
would like to be healthy for a long time
too that that's also a goal um so let me
dramatically oversimplify here so that
you can tell me if I've gotten the gist
of it
um you know the Circadian rhythm we all
know that we get tired at a certain time
of day we get hungry at a certain time
of day jet lag affects us Etc but
the impression of getting from what
you're saying is that in some sense like
all or many some large fraction of our
internal biological processes are just
different at different times of day you
know they're being regulated differently
like goes back to what you said how we
metabolize food is different during
different types of day and I'm sure that
when we're asleep versus when we're
awake
um so we're kind of like we're every
human being every organism is a
complicated chemical reaction but we're
different chemical reactions depending
on what time it is yeah yeah and that's
precisely why when we were talking
earlier about what makes biological
Networks special in some way I mentioned
that the these networks aren't
necessarily static over time which
components of those networks might be
expressed can differ over the course of
the day
and so the behavior of those networks
might differ over the course
so it was kind of like
I'm just coming up with trying to simple
analogies here traffic flow patterns in
a city are very different at 8 AM and 5
PM absolutely yeah and it's all and this
gives one hope that there really is
something called complex systems science
because these systems do have some
commonalities in there or is that going
too far are there laws of complexity is
the fact that a system is complex
whether it's a city or a human being
give us any shared insight there or do
complex systems have the features that
every complex system is different so you
know have fun but don't expect to share
Insight between different modes
can be shared across modes is the
approach that
used to investigate them right so so
one thing that is
that is in common amongst all of these
complex systems is that a reductionist
point of view where the elements that
you are reducing to are defined at the
very outset right like here are my cars
here are my genes
going to look at specific elements
is maybe not fruitful right you need to
consider the behavior of the system as a
whole and and coarse grain it so so I
think that those types of insights are
the same whether you're talking about
traffic flow through a city or or
information flow through a cell and in
biology in particular there's a
temptation to be a little bit too
reductionist right I mean not as a
professional biologist but in the
popular discourse about biology oh we
found the gene that explains X
I think I think it's a it's a temptation
just because of the way that we're kind
of taught to think about these things
but I think there's also a reason that
we tend to go in that direction and
that's that we know how to do
experiments on particular genes we know
how to Target particular molecules
when I go back to my experimentalist
collaborators and I say good news I
found a pathway that is associated with
the phenotype you're interested in and
this pathway contains 600 genes they
tell me to get out of their left right
like there's nothing they can do with
that you need to be able to narrow it
down to something that is
um that is targetable
um and and I think that there there's a
tension there between acknowledging that
what is driving the outcomes of a
particular cell or a particular organism
is a systems level property versus What
can you what specific element of that
system can I
Target to produce
an effect that I want to see good so
yeah so maybe in other words
part of what you you've emphasized is
this sort of coarse graining looking for
a low dimensional manifold looking for a
small number of
Collective coordinates that help explain
what's going on and then the next thing
is to be interventionist about it to say
okay you know how do you poke at it to
get some outcome that you desire right
and and is that I mean I'm not quite
sure whether that's supposed to be just
a cautionary tale don't expect too much
or oh yes that's what we're figuring out
we're gonna figure out exactly how to
poke at things and you know make us live
forever and cure cancer I don't know I
mean yes no I I think I think that there
is hope there
um so one of the things that that we're
really interested in now is so it
suppose that you have some sort of
wiring diagram or some sort of network
and you have measured the abundances of
the
the mrnas for the nodes in that Network
or you've measured the correlation
between the gene expression for all of
the edges in your network and and so now
you can use that Network picture to
start to make statistical summaries of
the network right so I can coarse grain
that data on that Network and I can do
that sort of coarse graining with
different data sets so you can imagine I
do this course graining with
tumor and I do it with normal samples
right and so now I can identify
statistical differences at the whole
network level between my cancer samples
and my normal sample
and then one can ask the following
question so so those
coarse grain statistical differences are
obviously due to
local differences in particular nodes in
particular edges right
I could recover the statistical
properties of the normal Network by
changing all of the altered nodes and
edges that were altered in my cancer
sample but also there may be other ways
to do so right so one can ask what is
the minimal number of edges that I would
need to alter in my cancer sample in
order to recover the statistical
properties
of the normal sample but without
recovering that Network in detail
and now I have maybe a smaller number of
notes and edges that I can then
go and Target experimentally so I think
there are ways to
um to bridge that Gap
I think also that that one can ask a
slightly different question which is
which is you know is recovering the
statistical those course green
statistical properties enough and you
know those those statistical properties
of the graph I can look at the entire
eigen spectrum of the graph of glossian
right chances are that entire eigen
Spectrum does not
actually capture all the you know the
the biological information of
consequence probably it's just the
leading eigenvalues right so how much of
those leading eigenvalues would I need
to recover in order to recover the
function of the network
I know I know it's getting late but I
will ask whether or not you think it's
possible to explain to the audience what
in the world you're talking about about
eigenvalues of a graph and looking at
the leading the eigen Spectrum looking
at the leading audio value I think I
know but I don't want to presume and the
answer is you know they should read a
linear algebra book I'm not sure
scribe
green geometry of the graph so so the
the
first eigenvalue and and its Associated
eigenvector describes the smoothest
pattern of variation across the network
so if you have a network with two large
communities that are only slightly you
know very tenuously connected to one
another then that smooth uh
smooth Vector on the graph would have
one Community having very high values
the other one having low values right
and then you can imagine
increasingly a less smooth patterns on
the graph right and chances are at least
I would say that those coarse geometric
descriptions of the graph probably
represent
the the flow of information in in some
coarse green way that is biologically
meaningful so maybe we only need to look
at the first few the smoothest patterns
on the graph in order to understand what
the graph itself is doing good you did
it without visual very impressive yeah I
know it is hard but I mean it's
basically you know in in some
sort of overly literal sense the graph
is every single node and every single uh
connect Edge between them but what
you're saying is that there are these
coarse features of what the graph looks
like that you can mathematically
characterize and maybe that's all you
need to know without all the details
being relevant yeah so my last question
and this might be a completely unfair
one you can you can be honest with me
here
um well we were talking about how to
focus the conversation before we started
I brought up the Phrase rules of life
because it appeared on your web page or
something like that and your response
was that's not my phrase that's the
National Science foundation's phrase and
so is it which is fine we all need to be
nice to the National Science Foundation
and uh but is it is it just a kind of
sexy thing that we talk about rules of
life so that we can get funding or is
the concept of rules of life
a reasonable one to help us contemplate
future research directions
no I think it is I think it is a useful
uh useful concept so the way that that
NSF thinks about it in the way that I
think about it as well is we need some
way to map between these microscopic
things we are able to measure right all
of that omics data and the macroscopic
things that we observe like whether or
not a cell is cancerous right or whether
an organism is is a mouse or a frog
um and and so the the idea behind rules
of life is that there are some
constraints or some organizing
principles that enable you to go from
that microscopic description to that
macroscopic description and the problem
is discovering what those are right so
what exactly dictates the relationship
between
the microscopic and the macroscopic and
what constrains it right so so for me
when I am thinking about well I want to
discover this low dimensional manifold
that on which my observations lie one of
the questions that one can then ask is
well why are things constrained to that
manifold right and and you can think of
of that as being one of those rules of
life
it'll never quite be laws of physics but
it will give us some insight that we can
tell ourselves about yes
yes that's great what more can we ask
for than that so Rosemary Brown thanks
very much for being on the mindscape
podcast thank you so much for
it's been fun
[Music]